[music]
Heat. Heat.
Welcome back to another episode of
What's Up Prof. Hello, Walter.
Hi, Martin.
Are you doing well?
Yes, I think so. We have to get through
this topic and we have to keep our
emotions in check.
That's it. So you and with everything
these days, we have to keep our emotions
in check because if we look at the news
and we look at what's going on around
us, we can get sucked in.
So let's pray about that.
Exactly. Our heavenly father, thank you.
Thank you for giving us the opportunity
once again, Lord. While we discuss these
things, we ask you to enlighten our
minds with the Holy Spirit that we can
understand and internalize what we need
from you in Jesus name. Amen.
But the Bible speaks about a time such
as never was.
And uh I I think we're really living in
a time such as never was. It is so bad.
One could never have expected to become
this bad. It's blatantly apostate and
evil.
It's evil. Yes. But there's a plan.
Oh, yes.
There's such a brilliant strategy behind
this evil plan
because it's going to wrap everybody
into the folds of error.
And the the problem is that it's not
open error. you going to think it's the
right side if you're not
studied
and you have to have uh a deeper
knowledge and the Lord must give us
discernment or else we're going to be in
trouble
those words deceive
and it's going to it's going to cut
across the spectrum. No denomination,
let me make that quite plain. No
denomination in particular also our
denomination
is going to be free from this deception.
That is true.
And uh let's put a disclaimer in right
from the beginning. It is very easy to
get sucked in and to climb onto a soap
box and say this thing has gone far
enough and then to side with the wrong
issue as a consequence.
Remember again what we've said from the
beginning. We are observers.
Look at these things. Yes, be horrified,
but in the right way. Ask yourself,
where's this leading? Where's it going?
And once we've discerned that, then we
can be on our guard for the real danger
that lurks behind the scenes. [snorts]
And we have to pray.
We have to pray.
That's so important what you've just
explained to everybody and we have to
remind ourselves also. So
yes because you can easily get angry and
say this has gone far enough.
You want to start getting
[clears throat] into things.
Ah and we were talking just before we
came on
about Moses.
Yes
man. that guy had to have a lot of um
stamina to go through the things because
to deal with what he had to deal with.
So, we're going to talk about true and
false revivals, but there's there's a
thread,
an underlying thread that runs through
it. a thread that uh
let's say say can lead people to anger
to be angry about something and as a
consequence
choose the pendulum that has swung too
far.
Yes.
So one of the things that is really uh
riing up humanity is the woke issue.
And it's so clever how it's done in
schools so that it affects children and
how they secretly tell children that
they are actually transgender and try
and manipulate them in a certain
direction. And of course, if parents
that have got half a brain left realize
this, they can get exceedingly riled up
and angry and as a consequence side with
a with an issue that looks morally right
but actually leads to death.
That's and it like you mentioned in the
beginning, it cuts across denominations.
Yes. even faiths actually
and the whole LGBTQ
oh there's an I in there now I'm still
waiting for the whole alphabet to fit
into it but uh we've got that now this
whole LGBT ITQTPD
is involved in this as it was in
biblical times as well
yes
there's nothing new under the sun and uh
this type of issue led to tremendous
mendous retributive action in the past.
If you take the tribe of Benjamin,
the entire tribe except for 600 men was
wiped out as a consequence of this kind
of thinking. It is it is actually
horrendous. Right.
Yeah.
And the world is heading for a
cataclysm. So, let's see if we can put
this together. Martin, I think you did a
great job putting these uh videos
together. Let's just put a disclaimer
in. Some of the things might be a little
bit disturbing,
but we've cut out the worst. We haven't
put the worst in there because uh it's
just too disgusting for words. So, we've
cut out most of the the worst stuff,
right?
And the this
the shocker is that it was actually on
national TV.
It's all national television. It's
because it this the the whole of the
population must be subjected to it. And
another point, it's not just a nation
here and a nation there. This is a
universal issue.
It is even an issue where people are
prepared to go the length of nuclear war
to protect certain values.
True.
True. That's exactly where we are
heading.
Yes. And it's shocking to see this.
It's shocking. And people are taking
sides on moral issues and values. And
eventually they all have to come
together. And I think we're beginning to
see a little glimmer of how it can be
done.
Yeah.
Brilliant, brilliant strategy. Let's
give it to Satan that he is a brilliant
strategist. Fortunately, he's only the
second best strategist in the universe.
And yeah, luckily we have a sure word
that told us this is coming.
This is coming. All right, let's let's
look at this.
Well, here's an article from the 1 of
March and this happened in Australia
and this comedian who is pretty
transgender it seems made some shocking
statements on national television that
are really designed to shock Now, some
loved it and some were disgusted by it.
Now, we're not going to show everything
that he said, but here is the comedian
on the one side and here is someone who
definitely does not look too amused at
what happened. All right, so viewers
demand an apology after comedian makes
rogue joke about Jesus on TV panel.
We're not going to repeat that joke.
It's too disgusting.
But uh we'll see what else he has to
say. Comedian Ruben Kay has found
himself in hot water after making a
rogue joke about Jesus during a TV
panel.
So let's not go into that joke because
it was disgusting. It pertained to Jesus
being nailed to a cross etc. And
disgusting.
Kay, who is best known for his off-color
sense of humor and drywit, shocked
audiences in Australia with one pretty
savage gag about the son of God, who
apparently is not a laughing matter.
So, if you're a fan of the big man
upstairs capitalized, that's pretty
blasphemous, isn't you saying?
You can see the trend of the new the
news agency here or the article that's
being written. It is also actual in
actual fact blasphemous.
Blasphemous. Yes. So if you're a fan of
the big man upstairs or his kid, maybe
don't read on. You know, Martin, that's
a disgusting way of talking about God
the father and God the son, right?
Actually, uh it's pretty revolting.
The whole idea why we are showing this
is to show that there is a plan to
disgust certain people.
Exactly. This is done on purpose.
It's done on purpose. Christians must be
rallied. They must be riled up. They
must become so angry that they will
react like a Muslim would react if they
said things like this about Muhammad.
So there's a plan behind it. That's why
we're discussing it.
And and and just to bring it in here
again is like you said in the beginning,
we must be careful not to be drawn into
this.
Yes, we must be observers. What is the
plan behind it, not what is being said?
Let's just say even Jesus isn't rising
from this brutal slaying.
Alli looked mortified and Harris burst
out laughing.
Two sides, Martin, that's it. those that
are mortified that something can be said
on national television of this nature
and the other one thinks it's a great
joke and that those are the two the two
sides. Moreover, many people watching
from home thought it wasn't the laughing
matter. Aussies raced to social media to
slam LGBTIQ
comic for his brutal take. I'm glad they
put a little plus there, Martin. We're
heading towards the whole alphabet etc.
etc. I [laughter] don't know what the
etc is going to be but let's watch the
news for details.
Now Martin before I run into all kinds
of adjectives which I don't want to
because again we're not going to climb
on a soap box. We're not going to take
sides.
We're looking at this issue. Not that we
approve of it. Definitely not. But we're
not going to approve of it to the same
degree as the rest of the world to jump
into a fire from a frying pan. We're
going to watch and see where this is
heading.
Yeah. So, the part that we've just I've
just put in a certain portion just so
you can see what happened there. But the
portions where he made the jokes is cut
out.
You cut that out. Good. We don't want to
be nauseated by his disgusting sense of
humor
because queer people, LGBTQIA
plus, predate any idea of God. We're
present in the animal kingdom. So, I
think it's hilarious when someone
messages me and says, "You have to
accept Jesus's love or you will burn in
hell."
Let's just leave it there. He says he's
a Jesus fan. Yeah. but in a very very
distorted way. So
vulgar.
Vulgar. Let's leave it there. All right.
So why is the world looking at this
diseased mindset?
I'm telling you, Martin, they're looking
at this diseased mindset to either
embrace it
or to be nauseated by it.
and to be so nauseated by it that they
will jump into the fire from the frying
pan.
There's going to be a pendulum swing
reaction
and when it comes
it will be devastating. It will be the
final event on this earth and we'll see
later that nations are taking sides.
That's the thing that you will start
seeing this is not going to be just
religious uh institutions. It will go
into government.
It'll go into government. And the
interesting thing, Martin, is the Bible
tells us who will lead out.
It's the second beast of revelation
that's going to lead out. Now if you're
looking at the second beast of
revelation which is the United States of
America Protestant
leadership in the entire world and you
look at what is happening there you can
be mortified you can be horrified
and I can use a whole list of adjectives
to describe it. You cannot even see that
this nation can rise out of this and
smack the pendulum to the other side,
but it's going to. And when it does, all
those other nations that are now ready
to even go to nuclear war to protect
their values will climb on board.
Yeah.
The United States is going to lead out,
but only once the pendulum has swung.
That's it. When it's ready.
When it's ready. So, let's see where
it's heading.
Here's the article in Mail Online.
Students stage mass walk out after New
Hampshire high school bans urininals and
shared locker rooms amid row over
separating bathrooms based on sex, not
gender identity. They are so distorting
reality
that to blend the genders they are
taking out the urinals and this is
causing an uproar of course. Okay, so
boys aren't boys anymore and girls
aren't girls anymore. Where's this
heading? Somebody at some stage is going
to say what are we going to do? We have
to stop this.
[laughter]
It's getting ridiculous.
So the protest started last Friday and
lasted about 45 minutes with more than
150 students walking out of the Milford
High School and Middle School in
opposition to the new bathroom
restrictions.
Friday's demonstration comes after a
lengthy debate by the board of education
over whether to separate school
bathrooms and locker rooms by sex
assigned at birth or by gender identity.
that a school board can take time out to
even discuss an issue like this seems
rather frontal lobe distorted.
It is actually I mean it's ludicrous.
Could you imagine it 20 years ago?
No, but there's no logic in this. So now
you have to sit there have board
meetings and meetings to discuss are we
going to have a man on the one toilet
and a woman on the other toilet
or are we going to just
All right. So it the point is it's gone
from the sublime to the ridiculous
and
it's probably going to get worse.
Well, I don't know whether it can get
well maybe it can. Yes. All right.
[laughter]
So the Glo Boston Globe reported many
students, especially the male students
at the high school expressed their
concern
the tighter rules could lead to bathroom
bottlenecks and detract from time in the
classroom. 16-year-old transgender
student Niko Rome spoke at the school
board meeting on February 6 urging to
reject the ban. So now even the
transgender boys are saying uh you know
let's keep it the way it was.
He expressed his concerns that the
policies could have a negative impact on
the mental health of the district's
LGBTQ.
He left out an I
I and a plus
and a plus. Yes. students. He said he
and other queer students just wanted to
be treated the same as cisgender high
school students.
Okay. Now you have to explain what a
cisgender is.
Well, trans is the opposite. Cis is the
same.
Okay. So, if you're a cis
if you're a cisgender, then you are what
you are.
I would am I am what I am or am I what I
was born or am I what I think I am?
You're probably what you were born.
Okay.
Yes. Now that's the terrible thing.
So that's when I identify with what I
was born.
Do you identify as a male? Mark,
you you identify as a male. What's wrong
with you? [laughter]
What were you born?
A male.
Yes.
Oh, I feel so sorry for you, Martin.
[laughter]
So, let's just see how these people
argue. They're arguing about Let's just
explain it a little bit. They're arguing
about the fact that they want to appoint
leadership in the school. Now, the one
that they're claiming is best suited to
be involved in the leadership as
president or whatever of the school is
very qualified, but unfortunately he was
born male and thinks he's a male. You
know, if he at least thought he wasn't a
male, maybe he would be better qualified
in the time that we are living in.
He would have been. Yes. Especially in
this case. So, let's just see how they
think.
I believe that Mr. Deleo would make an
excellent president.
However, I feel that electing
the only sizz white male on this board
president of this district
sends the wrong message to our
community.
a message that is contrary to what we as
a board have been trying to accomplish.
I think that it's important that we
practice what we preach and that
our words have strength when they are
spoken.
Yeah.
Well, the the truth is we all know your
heart is in the right spot.
Yes.
Martin,
if you were qualified to be the
president of that school, but you were
born male and identify as a male, that
would send the wrong message. You see,
unfortunately, you cannot have the job.
No, [laughter]
but well, you know what? We've had
similar situations in our country for a
long time. They call it affirmative
action.
Yes. And I have no problem with anybody
that's qualified
to do a job to do it. In the same way
sport, if you're qualified, if you are
the best, then you must be there,
whatever it is. But to put somebody
there because of
a political issue,
political correctness, it's always been
wrong. And I don't think it's biblical.
All right? But that's the way society
thinks. So if you want to send a message
that you want to be inclusive,
then it's best not to employ someone who
doesn't have the mindset of that
inclusiveness.
That's the thing.
Let's put it that way.
All right. So this is just to show how
far the pendulum has swung to the left.
Now what will the eventual reaction be
of those on the right? Because you
cannot separate this from the religious
issue because it is a moral issue.
That is the whole thing. It's going to
start riing up the people that's going
to swing the pendulum.
Now when we talk about religion, we're
talking about in the United States, for
example, it will be evangelicalism.
If you're talking about Russia, it will
be orthodoxism. If you're talking about
Rome and Italy, it will be Catholicism.
And that's important to realize.
Yes. And if you're talking about other
nations, it might be a mix of them all.
Our country will be the conservative and
charismatic churches.
Correct. And if you go to Eastern
countries, it will be Buddhist and seek
or Muslim or whatever it is. But
religion is going to play the ultimate
role.
All right. So let's let's just sum this
up.
It's a moral issue
and uh religion is deeply involved in
it. So you have the LGBTIQ
plus movement involved in this. Then you
must have the sports world involved
because sport really is also a religion,
Martin.
Yes,
it's a religion.
We've talked about it. It's a religious
service that takes place and it's uh the
enacting of the Gilgamesh epic. But
let's leave it at that. But religion is
involved. It's always interesting to me
when two boxers climb into the ring,
make the sign of the cross and pray to
God to help them to bash the other one
to smitherines.
And uh eventually when one wins he gives
praise to God for having beaten the
other one to smitherines. It must be
very disheartening for the one that has
lost. [snorts] His his prayer line is
not as effective as the other ones. And
the same in sports
whether it's a Super Bowl or whatever it
is people will be praying that they
might be the winners so that the other
one can be the loser.
Yeah. Well, well, I had a question from
young persons the other day and they
asked, um, but what about God-given
talent? Doesn't God want you to use your
talent to glorify him? And it made me
think and I said, "Okay, the problem is
in whose eyes is it a talent?"
Yes.
Because there are talents that God does
not want you to have.
So who says that if you are good in
something that it is a god-given talent
for that particular purpose? You could
have that talent for something else.
So you have to discern through what the
Bible says
correct
to see if it fits into what God wants
you to do. You know, when you look at
things like uh those movies where they
show, let's say,
uh mentally challenged and disabled
people in a race and one falls and
everybody rallies around, picks that one
up and they all go through the winning
line.
Then the people cheer like crazy because
that is is is such a kind gesture. It
is. But you don't find that in a Super
Bowl. Somebody has to win, right?
It it can almost if you like I if I take
out from what you're saying, it can be
in a certain
area that the way it's being done will
define if it is
yes
for God or against.
All right. So let's have a look at how
religion becomes involved in this thing.
Now we're we're entering into the realm
of where people are making decisions
based on their religious convictions and
sports people are saying I don't want to
go along with this agenda. It's contrary
to my religion. Let's let's watch.
NFL hockey player Ivan Pravar from the
Philadelphia Flyers declined to wear a
Pride jersey. Well, why? Let's listen.
I respect everybody's choices. My choice
is to stay true to myself and my
religion. That's all I'm going to say.
How do you know?
Any, like I said, that's all I'm going
to comment on on that. Um, if you have
any hockey questions, I would like I
would answer those.
Sounds reasonable enough, right? Well,
the radical woke mob is up in arms or
furious.
This is not good enough. Hockey is for
everyone. Dot dot dot. Unless unless you
don't agree with gay rights, is not the
phrasing of this. You're either in this
or you're not. And one last point,
nothing scares me more than any human
being who says, "I'm not doing this
because of my religious beliefs."
Because when you looked in people's
lives, you normally say that publicly,
you'd throw up at what you saw. You
would throw up at what you saw. And I
have seen that a million times in a lot
of different ways. So don't don't give
me that.
Martin was the man angry.
Oh yes.
Why? Because that star should have
identified with the LGBTQI
plus movement. Right?
You see he he didn't show any
acknowledgement or sympathy for them
and therefore it was riled up. So now
the contrary to that, we didn't show
that, but there was somebody who was
riled up about what the commentator was
saying and saying, "Well, if you say
that, then I want to throw up."
Yeah, that's exactly the the same um
comment news agency.
So we have two groups that want to throw
up. The one says, "If you don't go along
with this, I want to throw up." The
other one says, "If you go along with
this, I want to throw up." Do we have
two sides?
Yes. and directly opposed.
And on which side is the religious
component?
On the the conservative right side.
Ah
yes.
Okay. Pendulum.
Mhm.
Swing.
You remember we showed the the prayer
that was done on news TV. Now I wonder
what this person that said he wants to
throw up said would have said about that
prayer.
Yes.
See this is directly opposing each
other.
Okay. But there's another little mix in
there because Satan also has a gray
area. He could have complete liberals
also attaching to the religious side.
And we'll look at that just now.
I just want to climb on to what you've
just said. Satan has a gray area.
Yes.
But not God.
God doesn't have a gray area. We said
that last time in Mahanim.
That's it. People must remember that
there's a black and a white with God,
but there's a gray area with Satan.
There's a gray area,
right? Let's get a little bit closer to
the churches.
Here we have an article in the Guardian.
The Church of England to consider use of
a genderneutral terms for God. So the
Church of England is considering whether
to stop referring to God as he after
priests asked to be allowed to use
genderneutral terms instead.
So the right Reverend Dr. Michael
Ipgrave, bishop of Lickfeld and vice
chair of the liturgital commission
responsible for the matter said the
church had been exploring the use of
gendered language in relation to God for
several years.
It is unclear what would replace the
term our father in the Lord's prayer,
the central Christian prayer that Jesus
is said to have instructed his followers
to say together down the generations.
Just to say that said to have
places doubt on the veracity of whether
Jesus actually did it or not.
Exactly. I I I despise this kind of
language, but I'm not going to climb
onto a soap box because I'm looking at
where this is heading. Is it now in the
churches?
Yes. Oh, for sure.
Every church, whether you we we've shown
it so many times when you go to Europe,
in the European churches, whether it be
in Germany, whether it be wherever,
they want to bring out a genderneutral
Bible.
Yes. So, conservative critics have hit
back at the possibility of changes with
the Reverend Dr. Ian Paul telling the
Telegraph that they would represent an
abandonment of the church's own
doctrine.
The fact that God is called father can't
be substituted by mother without
changing meaning. Nor can it be
genderneutralized to parent without loss
of meaning. Are there two opinions? Once
again, two direct opposite.
Two direct opposites. And the pendulum
is going to swing from the liberal to
the conservative.
Yeah.
Because thinking people will be
horrified at what is happening. Nations
will be horrified at what is happening.
Nations will be prepared to go to
nuclear war rather than accept this.
Well, if you think and if you if you use
it as we've always mentioned, the king
of the north against the king of the
south, if you have to have it in a
spirituality,
spiritual form because if it's literal,
then you can't apply this.
You won't understand what's going on.
And this is secularism, king of the
south. So this ever since 1798
secularism the king of the south has
been pushing against it and now the
pendulum is going to swing. And it's
interesting that the Bible says that
when the king of the north finally takes
over the military is also involved
because he comes with horses and with
chariots and with everything even
militarily. Martin, this is beautiful
fulfillment of prophecy. Let's watch
where this is going.
So, now let's bring the nations in.
Let's listen to what Putin has to say.
And uh he speaks Russian, of course, so
you'll have to read what he says.
And it starts off here. They lie
constantly. Pervert historical facts. do
not stop attacks on our culture. What's
he worried about? Let's look at it.
Uhchech.
foreign
speech.
Foreign speech. Foreign speech. Foreign
catastrophe.
So here Putin is summing up the entire
problem.
Yeah. Of the west.
Of the west. And he's saying everything
goes in the west. Pedophiles
are the norm.
Yeah.
Male female distinctions are being
removed. The holy scriptures are being
laid aside.
Every religion in the world has a holy
book. Just have a look at them. They
will all condemn what's happening now.
We have to protect these norms. We have
to protect our families. We don't want
to be invasive in your personal life,
but we have to protect the norms and the
values. And at the moment, if you look
at the war in the Ukraine
and how the West is reacting to it,
sending weapons and sending tanks and
sending probably aircraft in the future
and escalating the issue and pushing the
issue, Martin, this is part of the plan.
It is. And if you if you have to put
these two Ukraine and Russia at this
stage into the picture of north and
south, king of the north, king of the
south,
correct?
You've got Russia as king of the north
because it's a religious and this push
from the south from Ukraine.
But remember, Russia is not the king of
the north.
No, it's exactly.
Let's make it quite plain. Russia is not
the king of the north. The king of the
north is the papacy and it's using
military power to get the pendulum to
swing. Let's make this quite clear in a
in an in an example.
If you take Trump,
he was accused of being pro-Russian.
Yes.
And uh Biden made a speech in Poland
recently which was like a cry for war.
He made a war cry. He was like a general
saying, "Let's take the sword and smash
them to smitherreens.
There are people in the Republican party
on the conservative side." He said, "We
must stop this. We must stop giving all
these weapons to the Ukraine." So there
is an anti-war lobby and it's largely
with the right
and it's actually
it's the other way around us. It's
normally
normally normally like the Iraq and
every other war it was
the other way around and now it's the
opposite and it's the left that's
pushing for the war. Yeah.
This is a brilliant brilliant strategy
and Trump is on record as of saying that
if he should become the president this
war would stop in one day. Why? because
he would say, "You know what, Putin,
you're absolutely right. This nonsense
has got to stop."
Yeah,
Martin. What if you then have a
revolution of the right
and the whole system
is swung to the conservative religious
side. Now all we need now is a powerful
religious mix into the movement
and the west and the east could unite on
an issue.
Yeah.
And they could say finally the west got
it and we can work together with them.
But the United States must lead out.
That's the thing. That is why a group in
the United States must come to power
that will reinforce Christian values.
Abs. Absolutely. And we we're not sure
who that might be. It might be Trump. It
might be someone else. But definitely
that is what's going to happen.
That's what's going to happen. And
that's how the east and the west
ideologically
are going to come together because Putin
has quite plainly said this is our stand
and here we stand and we will defend
this even if we have to bomb you to
smitheriness. Right?
Yeah.
Is the military involved?
Oh, completely.
Is religion involved?
Oh, yeah. [clears throat] Look, look at
it.
There's no doubt.
So there must be a movement in the west
that will move towards the conservative
side. Is it happening in Europe?
Yes. Okay. Here's the article from
January. Italy's Maloney fourth in list
of world's most popular leaders.
Italian Prime Minister Georgia Maloney
has an approval rating of 48%, the
fourth highest amongst the 22 world
leaders monitored by Morning Consult, a
US-based global decision intelligence
company. So, the popularity of the
family norms, the straight thinking, the
cis thinking
is gaining ascendancy.
At the moment they feel trampled and
they're going to rise.
Yeah. Yeah.
Another article, the Times rewards
Maloney. She went from being a danger to
the most popular leader in the EU. The
prime minister Georgia Maloney has gone
from being considered a danger to
becoming the most popular leader in the
European Union. This is what the new
newspaper, the Times, wrote when
examining the first 100 days of her
government since last October's
elections. The British newspaper
recalled that Maloney's major detractors
depicted her as a danger both for Italy
and for the European continent, placing
particular emphasis on the references to
fascist periods by members of the
brothers of Italy.
But what she really said was we need to
get back to family values. We need to
get back to religion and she wants to
keep rest and serve God.
Family, God and country.
And now just interesting look at what
what happened. It was a outcry that
she's
this bad person and everything. Now
she's one of the most popular leader in
Europe.
All right. Take Poland. Yeah,
Poland is on the same track.
Interesting. If you take Croatia,
yeah,
they just strengthened their Sunday
legislation.
Exactly. A very strong. And the European
um Sunday alliance that is also gaining
ground in all European countries.
The pendulum is swinging. Martin,
what about Macron? He's on his way out,
it seems.
We we'll have to look him.
But remember, he's just played a role
because he's Jesuit train.
They're all actors. They're all actors.
Now, we're going to jump back to the
year 2008
where the so-called father of the
religious movement in the United States,
Rick Warren, made a prediction.
Now, that prediction is very biblical.
Mhm.
Because the Bible says that that is what
will happen. Now, in 2008, it seemed
improbable.
Yes, it did. Today it looks even more
improbable, but it is behind the scenes
highly probable that it's going to
happen
from what we've shown and what we
because most of these things are not
very popular in the news. If you don't
search for all of this that we've shown
in the recent umh slideshow,
it's not that obvious.
No, you have to look for it. You have to
you have to discern it through the eye
of prophecy otherwise you'll miss it.
That's the thing. And so all of the
sudden when this will happen it will be
oh okay here it goes
here it goes all right and people will
have been manipulated to think in a
certain direction. Let's listen to what
Rick Warren said in 2008.
Understand that the future of the world
is not secularism.
It is religious pluralism.
You may not like that but you're going
to have to deal with it.
The world is becoming more religious,
not less.
The myth that as education rises,
religion would go down is that literally
a myth. They affect not millions of
people but billions of people. Pandemic
diseases, extreme poverty, illiteracy,
corruption,
global warming, spiritual emptiness. We
cannot solve these problems
without involving people of faith and
their religious institutions.
You can't talk community development
without talking about churches and
mosques and temples and synagogues. You
just can't talk about it because they
are the community. So my challenge uh to
you is can we not all get along?
Can we not just work together? I don't
have to share your motivation and you
don't have to share mine for us to work
on things like poverty, disease, and
illiteracy and things like that.
Frankly, I don't care why you do good as
long as you do good.
Martin, at what occasion was he
speaking? What was the backdrop?
The World Economic Forum.
Ah, are they involved?
It's amazing those days you didn't
actually take notice. I'm sure everybody
will take notice where this happened.
Now,
now the World Economic Forum, aren't
they in the paper bag?
Yeah.
Rick Warren, isn't he in the paper bag?
Oh, there's numerous videos that I don't
didn't even put in that where he's just
praising Pope Francis and the Catholic
Church.
Here we go.
And now, is he involved today again in
another revival that is taking place in
the United States?
Exactly. And like here, he's promoting
all faiths.
All faith.
He might just as well have been like
King Charles the defender of faith
because he like he said and he mentions
it in this interview. Muslim, Buddhist,
any religion has to be incorporated. So
this is an ecumenical movement like
nothing you've ever seen. And are we
seeing this ecumenical movement today?
everywhere all the churches including
unfortunately some that shouldn't be
there are part of this
and our prince Charles wants to be
defender of faith and not defender of
the faith let's see what he does at his
coronation
so all of these religious movements are
involved
uh the United States the protestant
world the evangelical world will lead
out but they will have been so
manipulated it that the ecumenical
mindset will be part of it. And anybody
whether they be of any religion out
there whatever it is that is on the same
wavelength when it comes to these moral
issues is welcome to join.
Even Even the Democrat will be very
welcome as long as he takes this moral
high ground no matter what religion he
supports.
Exactly. or she
or she
now what I just said Martin is not
conjecture it's reality
that's it
and here's an interesting case that
we're going to talk about now the mayor
of New York
now New York is a pretty liberal city
and they are moving in this direction
religious direction now not in the sense
of conservative evangelicalism No,
but everything goes religion.
That's the thing.
But it's a moral issue.
Ah, so we must remember who's who's in
control in New York. It's not the
Republicans.
No, it's the Democrats.
Democrats. So, yeah. Interesting what's
happening here.
So, here's the spokesperson for the
mayor. She's going to introduce him and
then he's going to speak for himself.
Let's hear what they have to say.
We know in government many times it's
said that one has to separate
church from state.
But we have an administration that
doesn't believe in that. We have a mayor
who you will hear from shortly who is
definitely one of the chosen. He
believes
in what the faith-based community can do
in partnership with government. He knows
that all of the great initiatives
throughout the course of our United
States, if you look back at our
historical
plightes and the goodness that has
happened as a result historically in our
country has always been driven by
faithbased initiatives. The creator had
the creator has so many times to leave
me, so many times to abandon me. Uh but
she has not
[applause]
when we took prayers out of schools,
guns came into schools. Ingret was so
right.
Don't tell me about no separation of
church and state. State is the body.
CHURCH IS THE HEART. YOU TAKE THE HEART
OUT OF THE BODY, THE body dies.
I can't separate my belief because I'm a
elected official.
When I walk, I walk with God.
WHEN I TALK, I talk with God. WHEN I PUT
POLICIES IN PLACE, I PUT THEM IN WITH A
GODLIKE approach to them. That's who I
am. And I was that when I WAS THAT THIRD
GRADER AND I'M going to be that when I
leave government. I am still a child of
God and will always be a child of God.
And I won't apologize about being a
child of God. It is not going to happen.
[applause] And so today we proclaim that
this city, New York City, is a place
where the mayor of New York is a servant
of God. Thank you. continue to pray for
us.
All right, Martin, that sounds like a
rousing speech, but his god was a she.
Yeah,
the creator is a she.
The creator is a she. So that's fine as
long as you're with the pendulum, you're
okay.
And this was an interfaith
g breakfast or something like that. Um,
so just to shows you it's very
inclusive,
very inclusive.
Okay. So let's see what the New York
Times reported on that little
discussion.
And Martin, this is all very current
news, right? This is what's happening in
the world right now.
Adams discussing faith dismisses idea of
separating church and state.
Have we been saying this for a long
time?
Well, you know what? You remember the
outcry that the liberals had on liber
liberal news and all of this about all
this Christian nationalism talk and boo
that said she's tired of this um
separation of church state junk. Yeah.
Now
here we go. All right. So the inel
interfaith breakfast hosted on Tuesday
by Mayor Eric Adams began normally
enough. A choir sang a rousing rendition
of my country tis of thee. A rabbi
spoke. So did Buddhist and Muslim
leaders. And then things started to get
surreal.
The mayor's closest aid, Ingred Lewis
Martin, the one that we saw in the video
introducing him, took the stage to
declare that the Adams administration
doesn't believe in separation of church
and state, characterizing the mayor of
New York City as definitely one of the
chosen as she introduced him. Don't tell
me about no separation of church and
state. State is the body. Church is the
heart. You take the heart out of the
body, the body dies. I can't separate my
belief because I'm an elected official,
he continued over scattered applause.
Mr. Adams, who grew up attending a
storefront church in Queens, identifies
as Christian, but of no particular
denomination.
He was elected to office with strong
basis of support in churchgoing portions
of the Brooklyns and Queens. But he also
has a lowercase Catholic approach to
spirituality and mysticism.
He has at least one Buddha statue. He
has spoken in earnest about the energy
emitted from stones. So he's a mystic
Martin.
But are we told that there is a union
between the dragon which is mysticism?
Yeah.
The beast which is Catholicism
and the false prophet which is
Protestantism. Do we have a perfect mix
there?
There you go.
Babylonian confusion.
So you've got the same problem because
you've got Christian yoga, you've got
all this Christian mysticism, spiritual
formation. This is all part of this
nonsense. And you know what's the scary
thing is the people that should know
better that's part of the remnant are
being sucked in by this.
All right. Now, let me just go back to
prophecy.
Babylon consists of the dragon, the
beast, and the false prophet.
The dragon represents God the Father.
Yeah.
In the false trinity,
the false one. Yes.
God the Father. The beast represents the
son.
Everybody has to bow down to him. He is
the king. He's the one who's crowned,
who's got the triple crown on his head.
And he's the one that received a mortal
wound 1798, who had a resurrection
when Mussolini gave the Papal States
back. The whole world will wander after
him. Every knee will bow. He's the false
son.
And then you have the false prophet,
which represents fallen Protestantism.
the three of them together and ruling
the one who will sit on the throne. All
judgment being given unto him will be
the beast.
Yes. And
and you will have to accept his mark.
That's it. And also on the false prophet
side, I was just thinking there's a
false spirit running.
Of course, there's a false spirit. And
all of them have to come together. Now,
this mayor seems to have a bit of
everything. He has the mysticism,
which is dragon worship. He has the
Catholicism which is beast worship and
he identifies as a non-denom
denominational Christian which is false
prophet.
That's it.
All of it together and he believes in
the energy emitted from stone.
Now you see so this is how where it gets
scary. Um even though you can say well
done Mr. mayor because I'm a Christian
and I believe what you just said is
great and I want to run with it. It
incorporates all these other false
things as well.
You're going to get you're going to get
a package.
Now modern we also get the entertainment
world into this. So let's have a look at
the great movie stars of the world and
see where this goes.
Welcome back [music] everybody. Today is
Ash Wednesday, marking the beginning of
Lent for many Christians around the
world. And it is the reason that Mark
Wahberg is with us this morning. In
addition to being an actor, producer,
and an entrepreneur, he is also a guest
narrator and paid spokesperson for the
Catholic prayer app called Hallow. And
this Lenton season, Mark is leading
listeners in inspiring lessons on the
practice of fasting happening with the
four teens. And what how do you do you
talk to them about faith? Like how do
you I always wonder this
I do. I just don't again I don't force
it on them either. Like before it was
like all right everybody's got to be in
Catholic school. We got to go to mass
every Sunday. But that can also you know
create some resentment. I want them to
gravitate towards it in a very natural
way. I want them to understand that dad
has to start his day by getting on his
hands and his knees and no matter where
I am the priority on Sunday is to go to
church. So to be able to do those things
and then just see them you know
hopefully they'll say well there's got
to be something there and let them do it
on their own. So for those who are
watching who don't understand what Lent
is and these ideas about fasting and
detachment, talk to them about why they
could whether they're Catholic or not
join in on this challenge.
I think we all need to come together
especially after co there's been so much
disconnect. People wanting to stay away
from each other and I'm always the
person who kind of gravitates towards
people. I want to connect with people
from all walks of life and we all need
something that's going to bring us
together and and and God is the only one
that continues to promote nothing but
love and inclusion, forgiveness,
acceptance, uh no matter who you are or
what your beliefs are. So yes, this is
an opportunity for everybody to come
together and start [snorts] to pray and
hopefully make the world a better place.
Earlier this year, Mark Wahberg's
passion project, Father Stew, a
redemptive tale of a rouseabout who
finds God and ends up saving his family
in the process. It made a huge splash at
the box office. Well, now in an
unorthodox move, Sony is bringing the
movie back to theaters at the top of
December in a new form. They call it
Father Stew Reborn. Joining me to
discuss is the film star and producer
Mark Wahberg. Now, this is an odd move,
Mark, to release a movie in the same
year it was originally released. Why did
you and the studio decide to do it this
way?
Well, given the nature of the the
R-rated movie, uh lots of families
didn't feel comfortable uh with their
children seeing it, but they really
wanted them to get the message. So, um,
because the archbishop, Archbishop
Thomas of Nevada, who had actually
ordained Father Stew, uh, in Helena,
Montana, came to me and said, "Mark, I
really understand why the language is
there, but it would be a sin and a shame
for young people not to see this movie
and to really understand the importance
of this story." So, we wanted to make
sure that we could share that with
children of all ages. And so, we recut
the film. We took out all 200 and some
odd swears. And the film is still as
powerful and as impactful Martin, would
you be happy to take part in a movie
where you have to cuss and swear 200
times to make it realistic?
I believe like he said in the end it was
taken out and it still had the same it
was still the same.
It's still the same.
You have to go that route.
No, you can't go that route. But he also
said it doesn't matter what religion you
belong to as long as you bring the
spirituality back in. Right. You see
that's that's why I think it's important
to know to see this look at where
religion is already now taking big hold
but which religion they all go
everything goes God loves everybody
he does love everybody but he has
certain criteria and if you do certain
things if you follow certain rituals
then you are deemed to be a religious
person. Oh, that is so true.
So the man is propagating Lent, 40 days
of fasting.
Now the fast is not the total fast of
course
that's not food. It's not
but you abstain from that which you
normally like to eat etc.
It's actually interesting I didn't put
that part in. He was mentioning that if
it's it that fast can be something that
you know is not really right and then
you just fast from [laughter] it for
this 40 days
for 40 days.
So actually what you're going then back
to it you see it's a very loose thing.
Now the Protestant principle is
Jesus paid the price. He's the
fulfillment of the law. Mhm.
Uh because Jesus fasted 40 days, does
that mean I must now fast 40 days or is
that salvation by works?
I think it's salvation.
All right. So this idea of fasting 40
days seems to be a universal thing.
Islam has Ram Ramadan.
Uh we're supposed to have faith in Jesus
and in his completed works. Mhm. That
doesn't mean that we do not have to obey
and live decent lives because if you
love me, keep my commandments, but these
are work-based things which create the
impression that you are religious. It's
interesting that he also appeared with
the Ash Wednesday cross on on his
forehead.
He's making a statement and he's part of
Jesuit theater which is Hollywood. So
Hollywood is involved, sports is
involved, the churches are involved,
the governments are involved, the
militaries are involved. Everything that
the Bible says the king of the north
will do is involved. So let me read it
to you. I I cannot resist it.
That's good. [snorts]
Let's turn to Daniel chapter 11
verse 40.
Almost there.
And at the time of the end. Now we've
discussed that, right? And we've
concluded from the scriptures that that
started in 1798.
Yes.
When the papacy received the mortal
wound and the political power of the
papacy was taken away.
Yes.
In other words, it could no longer be
church and state.
Yes.
And since that time, church and state
has been separate.
The consequences are total chaos. We
have the woke movement. We have
everything that goes along with it. And
people are beginning to say it doesn't
work. Separation of church and state.
And it started with the French
Revolution.
Yes.
With secularism
taking over and throwing out religion.
Correct. And Napoleon invaded Rome, took
away the secular power of the papacy.
So at the time of the end shall the king
of the south which is secularism
take away the power and the king of the
north this will be the retaliation
shall come against him. So the table
will be turned the pendulum will swing
towards secularism with its woke agenda
as we can now see and then the king of
the north will come against him. Now
he's leading a religious movement.
He's the beast power, the king of the
north.
Yeah.
So he is the false son. He's the
antichrist.
And he is the one that will lead the
movement with the dragon, the beast, and
the false prophet by his side.
And we've seen it. Everything there,
everything in the in the mayor of New
York
against him like a whirlwind with
chariots. Is that the military?
Yes.
Do we have threats of war on this moral
issue with Putin saying we will defend
the moral high ground?
That's the same
and the [clears throat] Bible and the
holy books of the world. He didn't
exclude the other religious systems. And
with horsemen,
does that include the military?
Yep.
Yes. And with many ships. Does that
include the economy?
That's it.
That includes the economy. And he shall
enter into the countries and shall
overflow and pass over. Are all
countries involved?
And he shall enter into the glorious
land and many countries shall be
overthrown. But these shall escape out
of his hand. And then it mentioned E and
Moab and the children of Ammon because
in the last days out of all of the
nations of the world they have been
pressing into the Christian
that's it
uh church and God has his people and
they are still in Babylon.
Yes. So this um is the religious part
and the people must notice and discern
what is deception and what is truth. And
once they understand it, they will say,
"We cannot be part of this movement
because this is the false movement. We
have to come out." Now, let's see where
this is heading because this is getting
very exciting.
Yes.
So, let's go to the great revival
because we're not going to have a
popular movement unless we have a great
revival.
So, all of this that we've just seen is
actually leading to this.
It's leading to this. All right. Here's
the Detroit Catholic reporting on the
great Aspbury revival. Jesus was right
next to me. Aspir revival sets Catholics
on fire with the Holy Spirit. Now, this
is a Methodist institution,
but the Catholics are on fire. So, this
is important. So, we have the false
prophet and we have
the beast.
The beast.
A Kentucky University has become ground
zero for what thousands are calling a
mysterious move of the Holy Spirit. The
local Catholics told OSB News, "The
experience has been profound. It's
almost like a wellspring," said Father
Norman Fischer, pastor of the St. Peter
Claver Church in Lexington, Kentucky,
and chaplain at Lexington's Catholic
High School. "You just know right away
that God is there." Since February 8, a
routine morning chapel gathering at
Aspbury University, a Christian liberal
arts university located in Wilmore,
Kentucky, has blossomed into a
roundthe-clock session of prayer,
praise, worship, and testimonials.
area. Catholic parishes are looking to
see how they can cultivate the same,
especially as the Catholic Church in the
US enters the second year of the
National Eucharist Revival, which will
include the 10th National Eukaristic
Congre Congress in Indianapolis, July
21-24,
2024. Martin, things are heading in a
direction, right?
It's amazing. You got a charismatic
revival, conservative revival, and you
even got a a eukarist revival. And this
is all under the banner of Christian.
Now, just saying that you can feel it is
here. Martin, can you base your faith on
feeling?
The heart is deceivable above all
things.
Uhhuh.
I think there is truly a way to tie this
to the Eucharist revival. Can you take
part in the Eucharist?
No. The selfsame sacrifice has happened
on the cross was Jesus's sacrifice not
efficacious.
No. You know what? To do a Eucharist
revival or anything to do with the
Eucharist is like hitting the rock twice
like Moses did.
And they're hitting it a thousand
millions of times.
But there's got to be a willingness to
be open to the Holy Spirit who can say,
"I don't want to be finished at 8:00
p.m." said Father Fischer. Can your
church handle that? Is it willing?
Now, there have been many things written
and said about the Aspbury revival. So,
let's just sum it up in a video
and see what the various role players
say.
Yeah.
Because there are of course many
prophets that have been proven to say
incorrect things in the past, but are
still considered to be prophets. And
they're saying that this revival is the
beginning of what must happen in the
entire world.
Yes, they actually are most of these
people believe that this is the fire
that's going to lit up this whole world
revival.
All right, let's have a look at it. It's
quite lengthy, but it's worth watching.
Today we are in Wilmore, Kentucky to
witness an outpouring of the Holy Spirit
that is [music] taking place on the
campus of Asbury University.
And what he showed me was what this
revival would look like. This blowing of
the breath again [music] intensely. I
saw the fire of God coming to the youth
of our nation, the young people,
campuses, college campuses. The fires of
revival began to burn. Completely
grassroots, completely spontaneous, led
by no person, controlled by no person,
planned by no person. [music]
God just began to hover over these
universities. I listened to these
testimonies and something strange
happened. The spirit that is in Asbury
started getting on me. And I remember I
went to go do a broadcast two days ago
and I felt so solemn, so quiet, so
muted. I realized that that presence of
conviction was already working on me.
And this is just from being exposed to
the viral nature of the revival that is
happening. Now, here's what I found out.
The last time this happened at Aspbury
was 1970,
uh, February 1970. Ironically, it's, uh,
it was right after the Kansas City
Chiefs won the Super Bowl. So that
Kansas City, and I'm not connecting
these two as an act of God. I'm saying
how weird these coincidences are. So
Kansas City wins the Super Bowl the same
time that revival breaks out at Asbury.
The Aspberry revival, as as Dutch said,
went to 130 different universities.
Well, this is important because already
including Ohio and down here in Austin,
different campuses are telling me
they're having a similar outpouring of
the spirit of God. And what's uh what's
interesting about that is I just got a
text from uh Bert Lindsay who tells me
the 1948 Later movement started on
Valentine's Day on this day to you know
on Valentine's Day in 1940 75 years
later 2023
Valentine's Day is right in the middle
of the revival again. So here we are 75
years later the latter rain outpouring
started on this day. So, I'm thinking
we're at a divine convergence.
This is just the beginning. This nation
is so ripe. It is so there people are so
desperate. They are so ready for change.
The enemy has overplayed his hand.
People are scared to death. They're in
fear. They're in turmoil. They're
worried about their kids now. They're
worried about their money. It's just
like the 70s with the riots and the and
the civil rights movement and the young
people that were so upset with the
establishment. We're there again. And
there's this desperation. America and
other parts of the world is is ripe for
a revival and it's coming. We've come to
a fullness of time. We've come to aos
right time.
50 years ago, something [music]
extraordinary happened on one college
campus.
We need him to change their hearts so
that they can change the direction of
our nation. We're asking you please join
us. Join us for this day of prayer. Join
us in praying for these young people.
Believe that God can usher in something
new through the power of our prayers.
Join us on February 23rd live from
Asbury University.
Lord, do it again.
There's [music] this church. It's called
Calvary Chapel. And we say we're looking
for truth. What if this is true? Cuz
everything that we've been trying is not
working for me.
I just can't be laid down again. What I
have felt in there? I haven't. What if
it's good for a minute and then it's
gone? What then?
We can find out together. [music]
Country is a dark and divided place.
But in [music] that tent,
there's hope
and unity and miracles
that I can't even explain. I was having
sort of a late night and I sat in my
living room and I was thinking, geez, I
want to do something that actually has
some value beyond just the fact that I'm
doing another role or uh something that
uh I enjoy playing. And uh then very
next morning, this script was delivered
to my house.
If if you feel like you're an outcast,
then
join us here. If you
from Graham, CBN News, Los Angeles,
misunderstood and judged. What a
wonderful trip down memory lane for me.
I remember this. I remember the Jesus
revolution. I remember all the turmoil
of the 1960s.
Well, also just something interesting.
Almost every one of the um speakers and
news people here said that they were
they are a result of the 1970 Aspbury
revival.
All right. Now, how involved is
Hollywood?
Oh, didn't we see? We started with Mark
Wberg. Look at this. Now, we've got
Kelsey Grammar.
We've got the actors that play the roles
of Jesus involved in all of these,
the roles of Jesus in The Chosen.
And there are many, many clips that are
going out now with those same actors.
And and remember, most of them are
Catholic, right?
bringing the world together.
And this is a massive movement. Martin,
what if this is the final movement, the
final gathering of Babylon and people
don't know it? Isn't that a horrendous
deception? Scary.
It is.
And let's read from the great
controversy.
But many of the revivals of modern times
have presented a marked contrast to
those manifestations of divine grace
which in earlier days followed the
labors of God's servants.
What was the watch word of Peter?
Repent.
Yes, repent. They were cut to the heart.
They realized that they were not living
up to God's expectations. They'
crucified the son of God. Now they're
doing it together with eukaristic
celebrations which crucified the son of
God over and over and over again.
And Peter was speaking to his fellow
disciples as well because when they when
Jesus was sacrificed they were also not
repented yet.
They hadn't understood the issue.
It is true that a widespread interest is
kindled. many profess conversions and
there are large sessions to the
churches. Nevertheless, the results are
not such as to warrant the belief that
there has been a corresponding increase
of real spiritual life. The light which
flames up for a time soon dies out,
leaving the darkness more dense than
before.
The same influences have been at work to
a greater or less degree that will be
manifest in the most extensive movements
of the future. There's an emotional
excitement, a mingling of the true with
the false that is well adapted to
mislead. Do we see this?
This this could have been written today.
It is so brilliant how someone cannot
see the inspiration in this boggles my
mind. Yet none may need be deceived.
Martin, as soon as you discern through
the scriptures one drop,
just one little drop of error. Now with
the Aspbury revival, how involved was
the LGBTQ
uh I forgot the I plus movement?
Very much actually. There are videos
that shows that it's actually what
initiated it.
Uhhuh. And it's a spirituality because
it incorporates anything error plus
truth. Catholicism plus Protestantism
plus mysticism. Everything goes as long
as you have the feeling, as long as you
have the spirit. But the word is the
norm.
That's it. Nothing else.
There's no other standard.
There's not the spirit is above the word
because that's where where most of these
things start making a trouble for you.
So let's read what she says further. In
the light of God's word,
it is not difficult to determine the
nature of these movements.
So what happens? The word is left aside.
It has to be
and the spirit takes over and then it's
a feeling and not says the Lord.
You come from that movement. You were in
that movement.
Wherever men neglect the testimony of
the Bible, turning away from those plain
soulesting truths which require
self-denial and renunciation of the
world. There we may be sure that God's
blessing is not bestowed. and by the
rule which Christ himself has given, you
shall know them by their fruits. It is
evident that these movements are not the
work of the spirit of God. Worship with
the bedum of noise. The things you have
described as taking place in Indiana,
the Lord has shown me would take place
just before the close of probation.
When Martin? Just before that day.
Every uncrated.
They will be shouting with drums, music,
dancing. The senses of rational beings
will become so confused that they cannot
be trusted to make right decisions. And
this is called the moving of the Holy
Spirit. Now, we didn't show the videos
of all the testimonies where the people
are giving these emotional testimonies
and the LGBTs are involved and anything
goes. sin together with non sin
everything is in the in the mix
and you must remember people were flying
from New Zealand from all over the world
to attend
and no matter what you believe and no
matter what gender you ascribe yourself
to you receive the spirit yeah
so can the spirit be from God
no
cannot be the holy spirit never re
reveals itself in such methods in such a
bedum of noise this is an invention of
Satan to cover up his ingenious methods
of making of non effect the pure,
sincere, elevating, enobbling,
sanctifying truth for this time. Better
never have the worship of God blended
with music than to use musical
instruments to do the work which last
January was represented to me would be
brought into our camp meetings. The
truth for this time needs nothing of
this kind in its work of converting
souls.
warning bells.
Are we in our denomination
subject to the same influences?
Absolutely.
Are we in the same danger?
We are even more in danger.
Do many fall into the same trap.
Exactly.
Let's look at what happened in our
institutions where secular stars come
into our institutions
and sing make a bedum of noise shout
their ears off as if they're speaking to
Baal who has lost his hearing and then
tell us it doesn't matter whether you
worship on a Thursday or Friday or
Saturday or whatever. And the sad thing
is
we're going crazy about it.
And everybody says, "Hallelujah.
Abomination.
I don't believe in God. I'm an atheist.
I'm an agnostic. I'm a
[music] you can't make me down.
Know too much about him."
But y'all be having y'all be having
services [music] on Saturday and stuff.
You can't make me down them. Cuz
the same God over [music] Saturday
is the same God over every [singing]
day.
Do me a favor. Look at your neighbor.
Make sure to hear say, "Pick your
[music] Sabbath. Pick your Sabbath. Pick
it. Pick it." Cuz you can't make me
doubt them. [music]
If you got to do it on Monday, keep it.
Know too much about them.
[screaming]
Oh,
you can make me
NOT TOO MUCH. YOU'RE ABOUT TO MAKE ME
run like a Pentecostal. I'm sorry, but
you can't make me
[music]
jump back.
Father
[music]
Martin, are we in the same danger?
Should we know better?
We should know better. It's a very sad
state of affairs. I was once, I mean,
I've told the story many times. Maybe it
fits.
I was in one of our large churches in
the United States of America
and I was supposed to speak
and uh the pastor was not very happy for
me to speak but the youth had invited me
and uh the youth pastor actually
appeared on the stage with an earring in
one ear hanging down to here, his shirt
buttoned open to here with an electric
guitar around his neck.
And I thought, where am I? It was an
Adventist church in the United States of
America, a very large one with a very
prominent pastor.
And they gave me 10 minutes.
And uh I told my story and stopped it at
a high point and said, "Sorry, I can't
tell you anymore. I only have 10
minutes." So the students went crazy and
uh insisted I speak longer. I said, "I
cannot." The pastor said, "I may not
speak longer." He insisted I may not
speak longer.
And so they made such a rockus that
eventually he capitulated and I spoke
for one and a half hours.
And
you you can barely give an intro in 10
minutes. [laughter]
Sometimes the Lord has a sense of humor.
Oh, for sure.
And it was of course a massive drum set
on the stage etc.
And one of the students asked me
publicly there in front of everybody,
"What do I think about these musical
instruments?" I mean, I've told this
before, you've probably heard it before.
And I said, "I'm delighted to see them."
And carried on with my lecture. They
were totally stunned. And then about 15
minutes later or whatever, I said, "Uh,
you're probably wondering why I said,
I'm delighted to see them.
I'm delighted to see them, I said,
because the spirit of prophecy says just
before the close of probation. Drums
will come into the Adventist church.
Therefore, I'm delighted to see them
because it means we're going home soon.
That's it. Well, we've actually read
that
um citation just before this video.
Correct.
Are we there?
We're there. We're there. Now, it's even
worse.
So God's people, please wake up to the
law and to the testimony. They keep the
commandments of God and hold to the
testimony. You have the truth. Why do
you live next to it? Please wake up. And
if I also can add on to this, please,
we are now supposed to stand apart.
Yes. Don't look like the world
and don't climb onto the bandwagon. Be
an observer. But be an observer from
right principles.
Absolutely.
A bedum of noise shocks the senses and
perverts that which is conducted right
might be a blessing. Now that superstar
who was running around bent over like a
chicken that had just lost its head,
shouting his head off, wasn't that a
bezel of noise? And what was his
message? Doesn't matter whether you
worship on a Saturday or any other day,
right? Directly speaking against the
word of God. And people in the Adventist
church cheer cheer. And that is inside
of an Adventist church where you
proclaim that God set aside the seventh
day, the Saturday. But now this
now that that jamboree that they had
there, was that any different from
Aspbury?
No. We've showed a while back in Europe.
It it's it's sad. This is really sad. We
are doing this not to bash the church.
No,
we are trying to show people please
start waking start to wake up.
Start waking up. Now in Germany, this
has been happening for years. They even
have competitions as to which band can
shout the loudest and then give them
accolades for it.
Yeah.
And uh that's not the church.
That's a fallen leadership within the
church. God has a church within this
church and there will be a shaking.
So hopefully these people will make
right decisions and turn their hearts
back to the fathers
and come back to the Lord or else they
will leave the church and join up with
the asperies and the other revivals and
they will no longer be part of the
remnant.
Yes. And a lot of people that are part
of those revivals will start waking up
and take your place.
They will take their place. Yeah. The
powers of satanic agencies blend with
the den and the noise to have a
carnival. And this is termed the Holy
Spirit's working. When the camp meeting
is ended, the good which ought to have
been done and which might have been done
by the presentation of sacred truth is
not accomplished. Those participating in
the supposed revival receive impressions
which lead them a drift. They cannot
tell what they formerly knew regarding
Bible principles. No encouragement
should be given to this kind of worship.
The same kind of influence came in after
the passing of the time in 1844.
The same kind of representations were
made. Men became excited were worked by
a power thought to be the power of God.
Notwithstanding the widespread declenion
of faith and piety, there are true
followers of Christ in these churches.
And let's make that point quite clear
again.
In those revivals, I have no doubt there
are many sincere Christians.
But when they get confronted with the
word, they must choose the word over
their feelings. And when they do that
and when they live up to the light that
they have, God will call them out and
they will take the place of those that
are within our denomination
that refuse to accept the light which
they've had all these years.
That is so true. And another thing,
who's going to take this to them? It's
our responsibility, our viewers and
everybody listening to this. We've got a
responsibility.
We have a responsibility.
We have to take this out to them. Before
the final visitation of God's judgments
upon the earth, there will be amongst
the people of the Lord such a revival of
primitive godliness as has not been
witnessed since apostolic times. That is
why it is essential that we look at the
spiritual aspects. We cannot only look
at this. We have to look at the
spiritual aspect and what has to happen
inside here. You see, and then you will
distinguish which is true and false
revival.
The spirit and the power of God
will be poured out upon his children.
At that time, many will separate
themselves from those churches in which
the love of this world has supplanted
love for God and his word. Just by
looking at the mix of what is clearly
sin in the Bible being accepted as norm
within these movements
must make people think.
Many both of ministers and people will
gladly accept those great truths which
God has caused to be proclaimed at this
time to prepare a people for the Lord's
second coming. The enemy of souls
desires to hinder this work. And before
the time of such a movement shall come,
he will endeavor to prevent it by
introducing a counterfeit. Is he doing
it?
Oh, this is what we should realize. The
world is getting into our church.
We have to make a bull work. We have to
stand for what is right.
Exactly. His counterfeit is running is
on right as we speak. busy running.
It appears that God's special blessing
is poured out. There will be manifest
what is thought to be great religious
interest. Multitudes will exalt that God
is working marvelously for them. When
the work is that of another spirit under
a religious guise, Satan will seek to
extend his influence over the Christian
world and this denomination here.
Martin, may God help us to wake up to
see and discern the times in which we
are living. And may God's people
remember where they came from. Remember
the pillars of our faith. Remember the
message that we have been given. Not to
partake in this, but to warn against it.
To warn against the mark of the beast.
To warn against this false system of
worship. The three angels messages are
about worship.
Worship him who made not worship him who
has this inclusive agenda which
incorporates sin and righteousness in
the same package. It cannot be. May
God's people wake up. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father, we are living at the
very edge of time
and soon there will be a massive
religious revival worldwide
leading people to pition.
Then there will come a shaking and there
will come an outpouring of the true Holy
Spirit with a loud voice proclaiming
come out of her my people that you be
not partakers of her sins. Help us to be
part of the true revival is my prayer in
Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.